how's everyone enjoying the first NDC in
the States it's pretty good fun I've had
a good time only managed to make a
couple of talks I saw the progressive
web app by Nick Molnar yesterday a lot
of that code were being made great by
typescript also Dave Neal's was an
awesome talk and leadership
yeah it's sounds like there's been
really good reviews so I'm here to talk
to you about typescript I've done a
couple of talks on typescript this one I
really want to focus on what's been
going on after typescript who got
released so quite a lot of people have
talked to me and said are typescript has
these problems typescript is evolving so
quickly and the things that I've noticed
over the last couple of years is
hopefully they'll come back sorry if it
keeps doing that if you're coming from
sort of a JavaScript background going
into typescript was a little bit
annoying if you're coming from sort of a
dotnet background a lot of the patterns
that you could originally do were fine
so a lot of the features that I'm going
to be focusing on to through the second
half of the talk are all kind of the
features that allow you to be really
expressive with typescript to sort of
match the latest patterns that are
available my name is Jake Ginn 'van I'm
from Perth in Western Australia so it's
a fair way to come it's been pretty good
trip so far I work for a company called
seven West media and specifically it is
an umbrella and there's three main
companies that are under it West
Australian news who I work for channel 7
who is the biggest TV station in
Australia and Pacific magazines which
promote and write a lot of magazines so
what the West Australian is actually
quite an old company we printed our
first paper in 1833 so from a Australian
standpoint it's really quite an old
company we didn't start out using
typescript our team is actually quite
young
that two years ago all of our website
was out sourced Yahoo was actually
hosting our news site and we decided
that as a company will take control of
our digital strategy because at the end
of the day printing the news on dead
trees is only going to take us so far so
what our stack looks like is we're using
react and server-side rendered putting
it all together with web pack note on
the back end so we're JavaScript
everywhere we started out with Babel and
es6 and we converted to typescript after
we launched the choice to not use
typescript straight away was an
interesting one because coming from a
dotnet background moving across to
everything's written in JavaScript was
pretty interesting for me but at the
time web pack the loaders around it were
just pretty immature before typescript
1.8 there's really pretty poor support
the nodejs is a module system commonjs
can I just get a bit of an idea who's
sort of a JavaScript using NPM node that
side of things
what about dotnet cool what I was
guessing so the node community has a
package manager similar to new get
called NPM and predominantly in the
JavaScript space there's two competing
module systems AMD which things like the
module the package manager Bauer uses
and requirejs kind of as a module loader
for that and then you have the node side
which tools like browserify and web pack
allow you to use the node module system
on your front-end client websites and
yet before typescript 1.8 not very good
support so if you're using Bower
everything's global we had a pretty good
time if you're trying to use new module
systems not so much we wanted to use
because we're react and redux you come
we want to take advantage of patterns
like rest and spread any reduces those
language features were not available nor
with JSX so those were kind of
showstoppers and we launched the website
four months later as a pretty short
build and so we were under a pretty big
weight lot of pressure to deliver and we
got it out there JavaScript great for
getting stuff done but later on we moved
across the typescript for a number of
reasons I and also just what I was
talking about if you're coming from a
dotnet background easier but if you're
coming from the JavaScript land there's
a lot of idioms and sort of patterns
that the JavaScript community use which
you just couldn't express in typescript
because the type system was not powerful
enough it's pretty interesting when we
dive into sort of what types brings the
typescript brings to the table
a couple of things I want to cover what
it is I'll go into that a little bit
deep of detail and why it will actually
help you also
introduction what it is who here is to
use typescript quite a few awesome we'll
go through that bit quickly then but
those that haven't the important and
then finally get into the features which
is probably what you're all interested
in so what is typescript it's a superset
of JavaScript that adds a static type
system on top of JavaScript so
javascript is a pretty loose language
you can it's object orientated so
functions or objects but there's only
really a couple of primitives you've got
numbers strings objects and not much
else
what typescript does is allows you to
add an entire layer on top of JavaScript
giving information about the shape of
these objects what you can do with them
if they're null all of these sort of
things that that you want to express so
if using say react there's all of these
helpers so you can define prop types but
they're all runtime errors what we want
to do is move all
all of those errors to compile time so
we can so we can actually make our lives
a lot easier the interesting thing about
typescript is unlike other languages
they dissipate a conscious decision that
they would support JavaScript as a base
level so you can start out with
JavaScript and that's valid typescript
and then you can just slowly add more
type information over time to sort of
get the benefits of it
the other interesting thing that trips a
lot of people up when you first start is
typescript essentially removes itself
when it compiles so in dotnet space we
used to run time type checking and being
able to interpolate interrogate types at
runtime we can't do that in typescript
we can only write JavaScript that gets
checked at compilation stage so having
having to separate that in your mind can
be a little bit difficult to start with
so for me there's a number of reasons
you want to get started with typescript
there was a a conference a while ago
called next Lane in 2012 I think it was
and that a panel of people who are
experts in languages so those area
Kamiya hat and as Helzberg and a couple
of others and and as in my Eric we're
talking and Eric asked him so you saying
that you can't actually write large
programs in JavaScript and andis
response no can write large programs in
JavaScript you just can't maintain them
and so Anders has a lot of language
experience he's the guy behind c-sharp
Delfy and typescript so his experience
around this was there's a team at
Microsoft that built the editor behind
BS code it's called Monaco when they got
to sort of around two hundred thousand
lines of code they were just really
struggling to continue adding features
they're only spending about five percent
of their time writing new features the
rest of it was just reading code and
fixing it
which they're not often introduced new
issues so they just found they were
slowing down over time so they adopted
typescript gradually to help them
actually start moving at pace again and
spend more of their time implementing
features if you're interested that
panel's quite interesting there's a guy
that does talks a lot about data based
languages and a few others but there was
a couple of problems that type scripts
trying to solve first one is down level
compilation so you are writing in ES
twenty sixteen seventeen eighteen
nineteen all these new language features
but we're going to have to support I
eleven for ages and that'll only run es5
so the first job is bridging that gap
allowing us to write new language
features that compile down second one is
type checking remove all of those
runtime errors move them all to
compilation failures and then improve it
development speed by types mean the
development tools have a lot more
context so they can help you out give
you a lot of useful features so they're
kind of the main problems that
typescript was trying to solve the first
one I'll just touch on a little bit a
little bit small better you've got the
different versions of JavaScript that's
this current state of the web we have
the state of server JavaScript depending
on what version of node and then that's
what we want to use so our gap that it's
bridging is between one of those the
more interesting one is the next two so
I'm going to give you a little bit of a
run-through of what typescript gives you
there we go there we go so working for a
newspaper whoa
as they Fr we can fix that doesn't like
virtual desktops clearly it'll come back
okay cool
good can everyone read that up the back
suite
okay so working for a newspaper we write
articles we've got a type that is
something like this it's got a heading
and a bunch of other things and then
we've got the individual content blocks
that can have different types so we have
a stand first which is kind of the first
important paragraph some text a
blockquote
and also some text with some formatting
in it
so quickly going to just write some
types around this so the way we describe
shapes in typescript
is with interfaces so I have an
interface and call it an article I can
then define what the keys are on that so
I've got heading and it's a type string
so we're telling typescript what values
are valid for that particular key I can
then say contents and I'm going to say
it is a well it's all of the values have
to be locks so this is where the
intellisense and the tooling comes in
I've got a type that exists in another
module typescript knows about all the
types in my project so I can actually
just import this from that module and
typescript will add the reference being
from net this seems pretty trivial but
it is a lifesaver when you've got a
really big project and you're actually
working around JavaScript
so that is our basic interface one
another thing about major difference
between say c-sharp and typescript
typescript is what's called as a
structurally typed language and what
that means is if I have another
interface called article 2 that looks
exactly the same I can actually assign
those variables to each other so as long
as when you're doing variable like
assignment as long as what you're
assigning has everything and meets that
contract it can be assigned so that's
also known as duck typing but type
scripts are structurally typed language
we're using react I wouldn't worry so
much not going into react but we just
have a simple function here that takes a
number of properties and then returns
some markup so this is a similar pattern
in view angular kind of not really but
we can now continue so it's a function I
want to type this function first thing I
want to do is declare an interface which
is the props like that first argument of
the function so it's just article
component props it has one property on
it which is article and it is of type
particle
I can then start typing my function by
saying this is an article component
props pretty easy it's picked up an
error which is I don't have a property
called content and that's because it's
actually contents its guessed that
that's probably what I mean quick fixes
this is the tooling thing coming in
pretty handy but this is not as far as
we want to take it so there's a feature
that is going to be built on in the rest
of this talk called generics who's
familiar with what generics are and how
they work cool got a bit of it
understanding so I'm going to make this
a generic type typescript allows you to
define not only interfaces but type
aliases so I'm going to call this a
render function and the render function
has some props and it returns a JSX
element and now I want to type props but
I want this render function to work with
any component so I can introduce a
generic type here and all the generic
type is is an argument to that type same
as functions have different parameters
generic types are arguments for a type
so I can now reference that type
anywhere in my type definition you could
also do the same thing with interfaces
you could make that generic and then I
could say options is a T sort of thing
does that make sense to everyone got
what generics are it's gonna be built on
the lot so if anyone's got any questions
just throw your hand up we'll answer
them as we go so now I can make this a
render of article component props and I
can get rid of my type definition there
and they're really the basic building
blocks of typescript we've kind of
saying that we've got a number of
primitives we can define types pretty
easily and it just I didn't have to
rewrite my coat I just added extra
syntax so that's kind of the goal any
questions around that yes
yeah so for those that don't know what
JSX is JSX allows us to write basically
HTML inside our JavaScript and what
happens behind the scenes is the
compiler just turns it into a function
call so if you're using react it'll turn
it into a react got create element of
type div if you're using view or another
thing it might change it into an H
function but that's all JSX
is so when I use JSX the those function
calls return a type which is JSX element
so Jess X is a namespace in typescript
and element is an interface inside that
namespace and answer the question ah no
it's oh it isn't yes so the question is
what is the type here it is article
component is a variable that is a
function so this is our assignment
operator and this is our function the
JavaScript and the type is render which
is a function that returns Jersey
it is a function exactly and the way we
declare a function is the lambda arrow
function syntax so not using the
function keyword but I could write this
as make it a little bit clearer so I'm
assigning a function to that particular
variable make sense so if I hover over
here it will tell me that that is a
function so render of article component
props is an alias of Sun like the actual
function so you can compose types
together and simplify them by using type
aliases make sense awesome
any other questions cool
jump on so intro to typescript gone over
a few of the basics I really want to get
into modern typescript and kind of what
what's come after 2.0 because the
language just keeps going from strength
to strength even when we started with
around typescript 1.9 we had a few
things that we had to make extra
complicated there's a language wouldn't
allow us to express what we wanted so
the first amazing feature that came with
typescript 2.0 this was kind of the
game-changer that has allowed every
other new feature to come out and it's
something called control flow analysis
so what control flow analysis allows us
to do is we have a function a type alias
called get log message which is a
function that returns a string right
it's a get log message function returns
a string we're then declaring a log
function so this is allows us to write
to the console and it takes something
called a Union type it's got one
parameter called message and it has a
Union type which is string or give their
get log message function so
can be either of those this is pretty
common in in JavaScript you can pass
like a string or an object's options
object or something like that we can
then check right JavaScript to check the
runtime type of that type so if typeof
message is a function we know it's a
function inside that block I can call
the function and pass that to
console.log what is the type of the
message variable on this line anyone
sorry string it is at runtime so before
this is where control flow analysis is
really cool before typescript 2.0
typescript would think the type is
string or get log message we know it's
not because the function returned inside
the if block there's no way I can get to
that line and it's still a function but
typescript type guides which is what
we've got in there checking if it's a
function they only worked within the
block I could fix this by adding an else
keyword and putting that in in the else
block but that's really not idiomatic
JavaScript so after it as soon as we
return
typescript we'll remove the Union with
that function type from narrows the type
down so it's only a string for the rest
of that function it's kind of an
important building block does that make
sense to everyone
excellent so that allows you to write
code that just works it's amazing how
much more intuitive this makes life
because you don't have to keep fighting
the type system the next feature I want
to talk about is kind of inspired from
this quote
software developer Tony Hoare had in
1965 invented the null reference because
it was easy to do
he calls it it's billion dollar mistake
and it's led to heap of crashes bugs and
just issues over the years and he
reckons it's caused about a billion
dollars worth of damage in JavaScript
you could say we have a two billion
dollar mistake because they introduced
both null and undefined for some reason
and this is probably the most common
error which quite usefully there was a
tweet by Samil hey hey this guy sort of
introduced glamour and kind of started
the CSS in j/s movement but he tweeted
out what are the most common sorts of
bugs and then quoted it saying you'll
need a type system but the biggest 710
votes about 50% of them undefined
I was only tweeted yesterday or
something so quite timely ah this is the
most frustrating error because at some
point a variable has become undefined or
it's not defined and your program just
crashes this is a great gift so over the
top so what they've done is introduced a
feature called strict null checks to fix
this problem it is amazing if there's
any reason for you to switch and start
using typescript it's this so in
typescript one all types could be
undefined so I've got I'm declaring a
variable X and its type is number in
typescript one I could have assigned
undefined to a number all types are
undefined and whatever type that is 2.0
they introduced this strict null check
flag so it's a flag config variable that
you turn on in the compiler what that
does is it removes undefined from all
types so they're just the type they
introduced a new feature as well called
unary types so unary type is a type that
can only have one value so the typeof
null can only have the value null same
with undefined there's a few other unary
types that you can now introduce pretty
useful we'll go into that a bit later
ah so now if I try and declare or assign
undefined to number or that variable
doesn't have a assignment within the
scope but compiler can't see that it
could be undefined you'll get an error
so now if we want to do it we can use
Union types and say X is now a number or
undefined and that's how we can
introduce nulls and undefined back into
our code but we're in control of what
can be similar idea to optionals or
nullable types in dotnet but it works
for interfaces as well so how does that
work well using that and control for our
analysis we have an logger here with an
options object the question mark there
makes it an optional prop function
parameter rather and it is a type an
object with one key pretty with which is
optional and that's a type bool so
because it's optional it's or undefined
but something ah this is where like
really weird
JavaScript idioms that and short so the
syntax around not options and the second
statement will only evaluate if the
first one is true and for some reason
JavaScript developers love doing stuff
like this because it's completely
unreadable and but anyway before it
wouldn't matter if we did this
typescript would still go ah options is
under possibly undefined so here you
wouldn't know if pretty like if you
could access pretty safely but now
with it turned on by comment out line to
typescript will give me a error saying
options might be undefined and won't
compile comment that uncomment it it
knows that I cannot get to line 3
without options being defined and then
did the same thing but put the pretty
value and I am him safe to go is pretty
is a boolean which options stop pretty
at that point it's now an object with a
key that is a boolean because Titan
narrowing has removed the optionality
and the undefined from the parameter so
really really handy after doing this I
can refactor a bunch of stuff and it
just works one of the things though
you've got to be really careful about is
never lying to the typescript type
system so if you say a variable cannot
be undefined you better make sure that
your code doesn't accidentally make it
undefined the compiler can only do like
it can only work with the information
you give it so let's say you make an API
call and the type says something is
going to be not undefined like it's a
required value but the API returns
that's missing you're now lying to the
type system because you haven't
validated the runtime object matches
what the type definition is so anytime
you're getting external data into your
program make sure that it matches the
runtime like the runtime will match the
compilation time really big one next
really cool feature
anyone have any questions so far cool
next feature which is really handy is
tagged unions so we saw the Union types
before what allows us to do this or this
tagged unions allow us to take that a
little bit further and write even
cleaner code so I've got a bunch of
types for my blocks I've got the text
block stand first block and block quote
each of them get a kind property added
to it with the unary type of text which
is a string literal so the value of kind
for that interface can only be text this
string text before we could do string
literals I would have to say that's a
string and it could accept any string
this is important because I can now do a
union type as we saw before so I've got
my blocks and it's one of those three
you can also get at the type which is a
property on that type by using the array
index ax so I can actually grab that the
three values and you can see the value
down the bottom and assign that to the
type block types does that make sense so
the type lock types is equal to all of
the possible values of kind from that
Union type makes sense it's quite a few
steps but what it allows us to do and
once we see this hopefully to make a
little bit more sense I can switch on
block kind so I've got a blocks variable
that's come in I can just switch on
block kind the compiler knows that I can
only have three potential values text
then inside that case statement I get
full type safety this is what tag unions
are doing so because typescript knows
that block kind is equal to text and
those were one of the three union types
it can type narrow it - that is a text
block because the other - that kind
property has a different value so that
makes sense so block kind equals text
typescript knows that so inside that
block it narrows it down so I get full
type safety around formatting inside the
block quote quote and sight are also
available through until he cents but for
instance inside the block quote block
here if I tried to access dot text or
formatting I did a compilation error
because it knows the type make sure that
we can't access things that aren't there
so it makes sense yeah I'm not so I was
just showing yeah so good question on
line 17 I defined a very they type alias
called block types and I'm not using
that anywhere that's correct
I just put that in to sort of show that
we can access the three different kinds
of blocks just kind of totally yeah
exactly yeah it's just an extra bit of
context
finally you can do exhaustive checks so
typescript has another special type
called never write and never as soon as
the compiler sees that it can get an
ever type in execution it won't compile
so what this is doing is it's returning
never and that means this method will
never return because it throws
so if I add another block type and I'm
missing the case statement typescript
will be able to get to that default case
because it's been added so then it'll
fail to compile saying they added
something like a a video player or an
image or something like that as soon as
I added that I would have an error
saying image can't be assigned to never
or something similar to that really
handy I said earlier that typescript is
a structurally typed language this is
kind of the closest thing that gives us
nominal types it's not quite and nominal
types are the ones that even if all the
properties match they can't be tied like
assigned to each other because say
you've got a flight and a car trip and
they've got the same properties on it a
flight isn't a car trip in dotnet you
can't assign them in typescript you can
but this just means when you have lists
of different things like these block
types way way nicer any follow-up
questions from that cool next one is
indexed and map types so these came a
lot later like 2.4 2.5 really handy type
so the scenario I'm going to use is
feature toggling and this is something
we have in fact we actually use launch
Darkly as our feature toggling service
so I can define a feature has two
properties on it enabled and can the
user toggle it because I've got a you
can go to a toggle page and users can
actually turn on experimental features
when we want to allow them to do that
what indexed features allow us to do is
say I don't care what the keys are on
that object but all values on any key
must be the same so feature name is a
string so the key is a string
but the value must be a feature what
does that actually look like I can
define my features as an object which
have two keys autoplay video name of the
feature or new article page once again
name of the feature so the first one is
just a feature toggle I don't want to
expose that to the user so can use a
toggle as false but it's turned on love
when players do that's super annoying
but I also want to expose our new
article page to users so if they go to
like slash features they can switch that
on but I don't want it turned on by
default we're just starting to play with
it so I can add any key but the value
must conform to my interface this is map
types index type sorry an extension to
mapped index types is mapped types so
here I've got a Union which is autoplay
video or article new article page these
are my two features instead of making
the key type string I can say all the
keys in the features Union are the keys
with the value of feature what does that
actually look like well so if you look
down here the type feature state is
actually the same as what we had before
except I'm enforcing it so if I add
another feature to my features Union
this line will fail to the pile saying
you need to define key whatever that
feature is you can also get the keys of
any type using the key of function so I
can go feature in key of feature state
and then put that in feature description
so this allows you to you've got an
object with a bunch of keys and you want
to transform the type of all of the
values you can do that with map types
while these are sometimes a little bit
complicated these features you've got to
remember where type script is coming
from and what it's trying to do so the
goal of typescript is to allow us to
type the JavaScript ecosystem one of the
things that we need then is if we pull
down low - or react or any module on NPM
it's just JavaScript it's missing all of
these types and there is a huge
ecosystem out there with all of these
different libraries that have different
patterns different api's all these
complex and different ways of doing
things these features you might actually
never use them unless you have to write
a type definition for one of these NPM
modules so there's a repository called
definitely typed and it contains type
definitions for all of these modules so
when you install a package of NPM you
can then install the type definitions of
NPM as well and then that gives
typescript the the information on how to
type check that particular library not
every library is covered so we've
probably had to implement half a dozen a
dozen different libraries so yeah these
this is where these sort of features
become super handy there's a number of
built-in map types so I've got an
article here which has heading which is
a string an optional byline key and a
the content blocks they have partial
make all of the properties optional
read-only make all of the properties
read-only finally you've a pick which
says pass in article and then pass in a
union type of all the keys I'm
interested in so that'll create a new
type which only has heading and byline
but it'll take the value types and bring
them across
this is really handy we use this these
features all the time to simplify it
often you if you ever use like object
keys you probably are going to be using
this feature to make sure the types are
correct this brings a problem so we have
a look at take this a little bit further
we have a style guide or a design system
for all of our react components so we
want to document all of the properties
that have been passed so anyone can just
go to our style guide they get an
information on all the props and the
docs on it so we do this with by
creating a type which is describe some
interface which is an object we then
have a map type which is key in all the
keys of that type so key of T and then
map that to a string described article
looks something like this it's a heading
with a string it's an optional byline
and contents this is problematic because
when we when we actually use that I
don't get in a compilation error my
optional field isn't documented because
the optionality comes across so we can
do that one better using type modifiers
I can actually go - question mark and as
it's doing the mapping if any of those
keys are optional it will remove that
type model or that key modifier make
sense cool before that the number of
hacky workarounds to remove type
modifiers was awful those are huge
github thread and you end up trying to
find it and copying these three
interfaces which do awful things with
generics to do exactly the same thing
the last big feature that I really want
to talk about is conditional types so
this is something that came in 2.8 I'm
going to take this a little bit further
I have my article summary which
it's up missing a state the top
interface it has byline which is an
object so it's not just a flat object
anymore
previously my documentation for this
would just be heading which is a string
and byline which is a string because
they're the keys I want to make it deep
so now my types can have Turner E's in
them so if the value for a key on type T
is an object so that again because it's
a little bit quite wordy so I've it'll
come back hopefully timing sleep so if
the value so I can access I'm going
through each key in that object type of
T I can get the type of the value by
using the array index ax and then
checking to see if it's an object and if
it is I recursively use the same type so
now I have a deep describe interface so
if it's not an object just fall back to
strength so that'll be the arrays and
and numbers and such so now my article
summary description will look something
like this heading of string by line as
an object which has two keys on it and
then finally contents so that's kind of
what you you get they're super handy
feature there's a bunch of applications
for this so we saw the read-only
interface before well that only is the
top level so if you access that the next
level now won't be read-only using this
we can make an entire object structure
recursively read-only
so there are so many possibilities the
amount code that I got to delete with
this feature was great discover what
I've gone over control flow analysis
makes JavaScript really natural or types
but really natural types are what you
know they are at runtime you don't have
to do that mapping in your head
strict null checks being able to turn
that on undefined there's another
function goes away it's amazing
tagged unions if you have a list that
have different types in it this feature
makes your life so much easier
it was awful before similar they're like
dotnet 1.1 when you didn't have generics
you just had this lob of array lists and
they had to try and figure things out
manually indexed and map types being
able to transform a type of an object to
another one type modifiers just making
it easy to remove the things that are
coming across and finally conditional
types so there are not that many
features there they all sort of build on
generics and a bunch of the other stuff
but I think in typescript 2.8 they had
well over ten new features just in that
one release since typescript 2 the
feature list is huge a bit of a recap
when it comes up we went over what is
typescript why you'd be interested in it
a bit of an introduction basic features
and a whole heap of awesome stuff that's
come since 2.0 got launched that was
modern typescript is awesome hopefully
it gave you some insights into if you're
not using typescript why you should be
using it and if you are there's been so
much released since 1.0 and early 2.0
days just have a look start exploring
you might find a bunch of better ways to
write code than you are now any
questions
the question is a lot of packages on NPM
at either bundling the types directly
but at least you are installing from app
types slash the name of that module and
do you think definitely typed is going
to go away so the whole app types
namespace in NPM is pushed from
definitely typed as an automated process
so if you submit a pull request they
will automatically compile those types
and then push them into a package on NPM
there's advantages to definitely tight
so the biggest one is you have a problem
with the ecosystem around if the type
definitions fall out of sync with the
library once again you're lying to the
compiler so there's a few things to
consider ideally if you put the
typescript definitions inside like
submit a pull request to that library
that's great but if they're maintained
errs don't keep that up to date you have
to continually submit pull requests to
that library and that might take a
little while for them to merge it so if
you think the library author or that
open source project will be reactive and
maintain those types put them in there
but if you put them in definitely typed
it means you can submit typescript like
pull requests to the typescript team
they will review it publish those
changes so you get up normally a lot
faster turnaround so it totally depends
or if the package is old and you're not
going to get a pull request in the path
published then yeah totally just put it
on definitely cut
so the question is if there's bugs in
the typescript definition and it's in
that library and it's in a feature
branch but not published yet can you
override it
so typescript has a thing called
declaration merging so it really depends
on what the issue is but essentially
declaration merging allows you to define
the module types within your within your
code you could then ignore them and use
yours instead or you can supplement it
so if there's two module like different
type definitions that have each have
like different things what gets exposed
to the compiler is both of those doesn't
overwrite it sort of augments so you can
you can kind of use declaration merging
to get around a lot of that if the merge
changes are incompatible then you'll
have to ignore those type definitions
and then provide your own yeah so you
can actually in the typescript compiler
options exclude files so you could try
and do that no one else cool thanks
everyone
[Applause]